(upbeat music)
And now, here's something neat
that I wanted you all to see.
Take a look.
Hi, Drew.
My name is Fernanda, and in celebration
of Hispanic Heritage Month,
I'm gonna talk to you about the history
behind the iconic Catrinas that are often associated
with the other Los Muertos in Mexico.
The first ever Catrina was actually
a political cartoon by José Guadalupe Posada,
and it was published in 1913,
during Mexican revolutionary times.
The original Catrina was drawn wearing a big hat,
heavy earrings and a gown that was fashionable
for women of the aristocracy of the time.
Since it was Mexican revolutionary times,
it was meant to be commentary on the hypocrisy of the rich,
that no matter how big your hat is,
how fashionable your clothes are,
or how much money you have,
in the end, we are all just skeletons.
And this type of Catrina is still recreated
by artisans across Mexico,
and you can really buy these anywhere.
Fast forward a couple decades,
the Catrina reemerged in pop culture
after legendary artist, Diego Rivera,
recreated it for one of his most iconic murals.
Now this is mural Dream of a Sunday Afternoon
in Alameda Park, in the historic center of Mexico city.
He is painted as a child holding hands with a Catrina,
and behind him is painted his famous wife, Frida Kahlo.
And over time, these Catrinas began to be
combined with Dia de Los Muertos,
a day where we celebrate life, death, and life after death.
And I personally believe that these modern day recreations
of the Catrina still uphold the same message
that José Guadalupe Posada was trying to tell.
It's a way of unifying humanity during
Dia de Los Muertos, showing that in the end,
we are all just skeletons.
I hope you enjoyed the little history lesson Drew,
and I hope to also see you rocking a Catrina
for Dia de Los Muertos this year.
I hope that you enjoyed that as much as I did.
(upbeat music)